Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. We realized that Lyme disease, autoimmune disease,
and other disorders that are chronic that people are suffering from can be absolutely devastating,
life-changing. It can literally steal your life away from you. We realized it's not an easy fix
and we realized that there's a lot of doctors out there that don't really understand how to
care for people with that kind of problem. Most people have been misdiagnosed.
What we have done is put together some smaller plans, six months plans for patients
that we can walk them through what Dr. Kelly and I have termed really coming from her thyroid
book, the 10 fitness factors. So she and I have trained our naturopaths and nutritionists to walk
people through six months of care where we're communicating with them at least every other week.
Having them have assignments, projects to do, dealing with ways to regain your health,
because it's a process. We're going to be your guide. You're going to be the hero in this story
because you're the one that has to conquer your disease. Ultimately you don't need a doctor to give
you a pill. You need somebody to guide you along this journey so that you can regain your health.
That's what the purpose of these plans are. Call our office, schedule a case review with myself, Dr.
Halderman, Michelle. We'll go over these in detail with you. Staff will go over them with detail
and how we can walk you through and guide you through the pathway to health again. We welcome you
and no matter what your condition that we can address it through these 10 fitness factors. Thank you very much.